welcome to this video playing pour du
jour if this is halfway right pronounced
haven't played them for a while but very
frequent opponent is some 13 games in no
draws node is 6mm after day I wanted to
go yeah okay I don't want some watch 265
against but should be too i don't like
that very much so i'm trying to do
something different here i have wanted
to should have played maybe a group i'll
type of setup let's see this is a bit
weird but it's not that bad trying to
get a little bit stuff traded and
increase the pressure on if i'm on
deform near bishop that if he takes only
for let's say this Bishop only for helps
a little bit to increase pressure on the
deep on
yeah and it seems to gain a bit of time
on the clock seems he was not really
expecting this this move I wonder what
is there something great instead of just
taking I mean what is it just
disconnected no now we took ok ok ok I'm
going to take the night and then 96 for
I can check on deform on 96 96 695 not
sure okay but it's not bad right I mean
the long diagonal is opened up it's just
some some point to that if he takes it
the question is 95 or not
well he advanced so 95 I guess yeah I
wonder ever banco like setup is is in
order or not i'm going to check and
prepare be five now let's go be 5 a-2
hangs so okay just place it in a simple
fashion let's see i'm attacking the pawn
why can I not take the pond is he
trapping my queen I don't see it check I
can give the check on c3 but i have e to
i can take your first let's do that and
I also just have Luke v8 by the way now
that's also not a bad idea sorry and a
bit bit quicker here you want the beef
I'll still have a two I checked and you
still does not take ad so what is the
problem I know I'm taking it Quincy
three check f6r okay one can be true
don't don't get it
I think I could have taken it before but
I wasn't totally sure
I don't don't see any very substantial
play for him maybe like a fire trying to
open up a file and the dark square has a
bit but not sure that it is very
dangerous though check okay of six is a
move that think I'm okay with just them
also blocking five that that's not
happening kk yeah okay one I have rook
be one and then winning two pounds efore
will fall
now the threatening a rupee 3 which
would push the Queen back to e1
now that looks like a winner really
droopy three is a pretty big light
writers I yeah and he's down on one
minute yeah I don't know the dead looked
that looked quite comfortable here but I
shouldn't be as quickly taking over as I
did I don't don't know here would be one
be fine so it looks normal computer
suggest before that's an interesting
idea making use of the rukon be one
that's okay for white that's okay I'm
something like this is just just equal
yeah I think you should do something a
little bit more active and T i think i
can check but I really I wasn't totally
totally sure like we think about this
kind of cancer here here ok one Queenie
two and then I was thinking okay maybe
you can go f3 or something and then yeah
I have before yeah I'm just about
untangling here before here and there i
have ever it's okay i wasn't i didn't
want to get my queen trapped I recently
had my queen trapped in a game in a
blitz game it was kind of awkward and he
I'm just safe and okay I mean oke for
just gives away the pawn it was kind of
mysterious you can play Quincy two or a
three or whatever yeah you know now I'm
dying if this absolutely absolutely
nothing there so
I was interesting in the opening here um
here I can also take that also was
interesting Queen takes 97 threatening
95 but I wasn't completely sure about
this position I'm better developed but
he's got the two bishops yeah I think
it's equal ish this this my position is
very active and the night we'll have a
good place on c5 so I'm not worse okay
thanks for watching